[Applause]
all right let's say hi to uh ariana
barry hi hi arianna hi how are you guys
so what is it going to be a truth or a
dare dare a dare okay hit us we're down
drew yeah i dare you to use ross's phone
to text ross's fiance pretending to be
him okay
wait what okay i'm like come in
wait what is she gonna say you're
whatever you want whatever you want drew
i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do this one
i'm gonna
i'm going
to come home tonight
and i want you to be wearing nothing
oh
and
we're gonna howl at the moon
the only problem with this is you said
the only problem with this is he's gonna
know this is not me because i have never
texted anything like that
howl at the moon
why did he write back oh my gosh he
wrote a crying emoji and a kissy heart
mouth
oh my god ariana that's so fun we've
never done something like that oh i'm
texting that was drew that was true that
was true
i think you should text back
[Applause]
thank you arianna
[Applause]
that was so much fun and you're so
beautiful
so is everyone here thank you so much
for choosing to spend your time with us
we make this show for you so
take it with you
[Music]